we are very peaceful people so it was a  total setup to me it was the fbi had set  it up i don't believe that they were  trump supporters that did that right you  said the whole thing's a setup you don't  really believe that do you i do  i do  because trump won the election  they they  they've proven it over and over again i  really don't think trump had much to do  other than people that were supporters  for him  some were involved but i think they were  enticed by  the fbi this is why i say we have to  take very seriously the possibility of  something even worse in 2024  listen to what these people are saying  there's no there's no entry point to  disabuse these folks of these false  beliefs  and by by  you know undercover agents  dear god